je suis devenu la dame qu'on sort une
fois par an de son placard
moi je te le dis
moi au début j'ai fait effectivement on
a fait un pilote d'une émission qui est
passé une semaine qui s'appelait les
Français ont du génie je crois un truc
comme ça et puis après j'ai fait Danse
avec les stars
et puis après j'ai fait mon plus beau
Noël et mes plus belles vacances et
maintenant je suis pour les chats les
missions pour les chats bien sûr et
après et ben j'ai fait maintenant j'ai
fait une fois par an mes plus belles
vacances
il y en a d'autres qui se plaignent et
vous allez voir parce que ça fait
polémique ça énerve un petit peu les
gens est-ce que vous êtes d'accord ou
pas est-ce qu'il faut être sincère et le
dire comme elle ou au contraire il faut
se remettre en question en général un
animateur ne sait pas faire donc en
pleine promotion de choses c'est ce
qu'elle a dit après les beaux jours de
M6 be and Co bon ben elle dit que voilà
je suis venu la dame qu'on sort une fois
par an de son placard au début on a fait
le démission qui est passé une semaine
et qui s'appelait les Français ont du
génie j'ai fait Danse avec les stars
Camille il m'avait demandé mon plus beau
Noël La vie secrète des chats genre
vraiment j'ai tout fait hein j'ai parlé
des chats vidéo gags et puis maintenant
on me sort une fois par an pour les
vacances donc elle est un petit peu
énervée c'était pas la seule hein il y
avait Alex Goude qui ne comprend pas
qu'il soit plus à la télé c'est bien le
seul qui ne comprennent pas et puis par
qui dit ça
Christophe Dechavanne non c'est pas
on l'embrasse mais vous pourquoi bah je
sais pas j'ai envie de l'embrasser et
m'embrasser si tu veux mais vaut mieux
être heureux à l'antenne je te promets
donc voilà Christophe Dechavanne qui
avait dit ça Julien Lepers aussi qui
s'était plat bref il y en a beaucoup qui
en pense toi oui ben je trouve ça
incroyable parce que on sait que la
télévision enfin on a la lumière qu'on
animateur comme toi comme Laurent etc
c'est un monde cruel c'est qu'on peut
dégager on est en perpétuel
perpétuelle permission perpétuellement
sur un siège éjectable voilà mais il y a
pas il y a pas de raison d'être aigri il
faut arrêter de voir des complots
partout les producteurs et les patrons
de chaîne sont pas débiles au point de
ne pas mettre à l'antenne quelqu'un qui
est bankable donc c'est les plus beaux
kebubs c'est les plus à l'antenne c'est
à elle de se poser les bonnes questions
elle est plus dans l'air du temps elle
était passée bonne elle était bonne pour
un format pas pour un autre mais voilà
s'il faut arrêter d'accuser les autres
c'est comme ça faut faire autre chose et
puis c'est tout fait partie de ces gens
qui effectivement accuse toujours les
autres mais toujours les jamais se
remettre en question
moi je sais mais pour les
téléspectateurs c'est sur TF1
le premier jour en fait avec un
téléphone oui on peut chanter bonjour
Chantal vous vous posez quoi c'est
exactement ça il y avait une espèce de
jeu un peu prétexte et des gens qui
appelaient bon bref et donc c'était donc
j'avais une exclusivité donc sur TF1 on
était extrêmement grassement bien payé
avec une exclu et en plus je faisais
beaucoup de prime avec Jean-Pierre
Foucault à l'époque je me rappelle et ça
allait jusqu'à 80000 à l'époque par mois
quoi
c'était énorme bien sûr par mois
tu peux refermer tu gagnes 100000 euros
par mois je faisais une quotidienne et
tous les jours tous les matins sur
tf1000 francs certains mois pas tous les
mois il y avait des mots à 90
vous imaginez à 20 ans enfin 22 ans ma
fille je les prends ils sont patates
Benjamin a dit que quand il était au
plus fort le TF1 en plus de ses salaires
pour les émissions il touchait 30000
euros par mois
à 30 000 € de tomber déjà ça
marche pour les animaux
là on est parti sur un autre sujet moi
les gens qui cartonnent et qui gagnent
de l'argent les sous-marins et les
machins c'est qu'ils en rapportent là on
est en train de parler de ces animateurs
qui viennent un peu comme les people
maintenant pour la retraite qui viennent
dire on m'appelle pas c'est l'image que
j'ai donné tout à l'heure c'est comme si
on avait un chanteur qui réveille qui
disait ben je viens vous dire qu'en ce
moment dans une n'était pas complet
comment vous l'expliquez bah c'est que
les gens veulent pas venir mais ça peut
être la dernière chance comme un
électrochoc c'est un signal qu'ils
envoient
ça marche jamais la victimisation tu
donnes pas envie excuse-moi quand tu
fais pitié quand tu fais pitié on a
envie d'aller vers toi pas du tout nous
on a arrêté nous on arrêtait en
2008-2009 avec Pascal sur TF1 pas une
seule fois vous verrez une phrase de
Pascal ou moi nous plaignons d'avoir été
maltraité on n'a pas arrêté de dire au
contraire que ben on connaissait les
règles du jeu la règle du jeu c'est ça
marche moins tu vires et bah tu vires
surtout pardon tu changes de métier
parce que la problématique de tous ces
gens là attends rien faire d'autre mais
rien pour beaucoup je vous assure pour
beaucoup de 30 secondes j'ai une
question pour Laurent comment ça s'est
arrêté l'Europe est-ce que très
honnêtement dis-moi la vérité tu t'es
quand même dit ouais dans trois quatre
mois le téléphone sonne non franchement
non quand même non parce que tu quittes
TF1 le téléphone va passer facilement
franchement c'est parce que TF1 c'est
une chaîne on avait nos guignol nous on
était très marqués on était ceux qu'ils
ont de la télé populaire pas de bonne
qualité avant d'aller à France 2 à M6
etc personne nous appelait si on a fait
un peu de chaîne câble oui
je suis désolé tu dis tu changes de
métier mais c'est très compliqué quand
tu étais sûr médiatisé tu vas changer de
métier tu l'as demandé le boulanger
qui sont devenus psychothérapage
quand je commence à la télé j'ai eu la
chance d'être formé par Fogiel et qui
met qui va être dép directeur des
programmes qu'un jour n'aimerait pas ta
gueule c'est pas de dégager l'antenne
c'est donc j'ai ouvert ma boîte de prod
je produis 25 dollars par an et mon vrai
métier c'est ça parce que c'est trop
fragile l'antenne et tout le monde n'a
pas la capacité intellectuelle moi
demain tout s'arrête pas beaucoup mais
alors moi j'ai pas ouvert de boîte de
proches je travaille dans une boîte de
prod tu peux le faire toi aussi mais ça
je sais même pas écrire ma peau
juste c'est pas te dire que tu sois
là je peux
dire alors pas tous en même temps la
vraie question la vraie question moi je
trouve que c'est un dessin parce que en
fait ce que tu es en train de dire c'est
elles sont en train de dire le public me
veut mais pas les chaînes mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils en fait moi je vais vous dire
quelque chose la nature Aurore du vide
et moi je vais vous dire la vraie vérité
quand j'ai quitté TPMP je vous le jure
c'est vrai que je vais vous dire je
pensais vraiment dans mon canapé je
devrais choisir TF1 M6 comment ça en
parler aux potes chez qui j'irai
au bout d'un mois j'avais bien réfléchi
bon téléphone ce n'est pas j'ai pris un
deuxième mois pour bien réfléchir un
troisième mois j'avais bien j'étais acté
et Siri t'a rappelé j'étais acté mais la
nature horreur du vide quand on voit
plus on en met un autre et c'est fini
bien sûr
la vraie question qui se pose pas parce
que c'est toujours un peu le même profil
d'animateur qui se plaignent de cette
façon-là et Valérie Damidot moi je
l'aime beaucoup mais c'est vrai qu'elle
a été dans un format très identifié
pendant 15 ans il s'appelait déco
D&CO qui fonctionnait très bien elle
avait un public particulier est-ce que
Stéphane Plaza si demain il allait sur
TF1 pour faire d'autres choses d'autres
est-ce que ça marcherait moi je suis sûr
il est vraiment super malin il a créé
aucune inquiétude
Plaza c'est qu'il est parti de ces gens
qui vous disent ça rigole je suis plus à
Richard je tombe l'argent qu'est-ce que
c'est je connais même pas on rigole à
Gaga tu parles c'est un d'homme
d'affaires péter de pognard
de Valérie Damidot ça vous a plu
autrement
anglais
je pense que vous avez raison le
téléphone ne sonne pas en revanche vous
pouvez appeler aussi des chaînes non non
non
pardonnez-moi mais moi c'est ce que j'ai
fait et j'ai rebondi sur France 2
etc etc mais quand vous avez quelque
chose à vendre moi j'étais dans
l'édition donc je voilà je connaissais
mon métier de livre de critique etc je
me suis retrouvé à faire ça balance à
Paris avec nolo et avec Mazarine parjo
etc j'avais quelque chose à vendre
est-ce qu'elle a quelque chose à vendre
qu'est-ce qu'elle propose comme émission
je travaille en off et je peux vous dire
que c'est qu'ils sont tous relous un
Christophe de chat non mais c'est la
vérité c'est toi
relou c'est que c'est des gens peut-être
qu'ils marchent mais les chaînes en ont
marre c'est aussi parfois une histoire
de caractère et personnalité
elle pratique pas la langue de bois et
on dit oh là là elle se plaint non elle
explose
comme on dit toujours ce sont des gens
compliqués ou ce sont des gens
perfectionnistes traduisez